good morning Hank it's Tuesday so full
disclosure I'm a little bit flustered
right now because Time magazine just
released its list of the top 10 novels
of the year and The Fault in Our Stars
is first like first above all the other
books released in 2012 like I'm ahead of
Hilary mantel and Zadie Smith and Junot
Diaz and JK freaking Rowling so right
now I'm just a little bit overwhelmed
and excited and like wow by the way
Henry painting isn't he a genius so but
right a couple weeks ago I visited my
alma mater Hogwarts I mean Kenyon
College a small upper art school in Ohio
where I learned so much about how to
read and write from brilliant professors
in small classrooms I mean this is where
I became a writer and an adult and I've
made a proper thoughts from places video
which you can find at canyons channel in
the doobly-doo but while I was there I
couldn't stop thinking about how
privileged I am like for one thing my
race and gender and sex and orientation
are all privileged by the social order
in which I live but I was also
outrageously privileged to be able to
attend a college like Kenyon where I had
small classes and amazing professors who
carefully read my papers and responded
to them thoughtfully and I'm also
privileged because I had access to
high-speed Internet in 2007 Hank and you
and I could afford cheap horrible video
cameras to begin Brotherhood 2.0 I mean
Hank vlogbrothers crash course I show
the Lizzie Bennet diaries VidCon all of
these things wouldn't exist if we hadn't
had 249 dollars to spend on video
cameras at the end of 2006 and that's a
big part of the reason I feel so
strongly about trying to extend access
to opportunities to more people there
are a lot of people who can bring
awesome things into this world but are
lacking the opportunities to do so which
brings me to the sixth annual project
for awesome so every year on December
17th the nerdfighter and YouTube
communities come together to decrease
worldsuck
and there are two parts to the project
for awesome the video part and the other
part sometimes in between jump cuts I
think about the fact that Time magazine
just named my book the best book of the
year and I feel like a right to the
video part at noon Eastern 5 p.m. GMT on
December 17th upload a video about a
nonprofit organization or cause you
believe in try to be creative and
remember it's great if you can show the
organization doing its work then you can
embed your video at
projectforawesome.com and people will
vote for it and there will also be a
48-hour project for awesome livestream
where we work together to find and
promote project for awesome videos by
commenting liking favoriting tweeting
tumblr ring I'm tired of gerunds and the
other part is that we'll be raising
money for the foundation to decrease
worldsuck which money will be
distributed to the organizations
featured in the videos that get the five
most votes at projectforawesome.com
although wait a second it's important to
note that's done at the discretion of
the project for awesome Board of
Directors which is all nerdfighters
because like if 4chan comes in and rigs
the vote for like the National
Association of people who hate nerds
then ya know how much money will it be
that is largely up to you but we do
already have more than $15,000 thanks to
nerd craft area donations and also
because the people who made the evil
baby orphanage card game quietly donated
a portion of the proceeds to the
foundation also as in previous years
Hank and I will donate one penny per
project for awesome comment up to 1
million comments and most excitingly
thanks to four awesome donors who wish
to remain anonymous every dollar that is
donated to the foundation to decrease
worldsuck will be matched up to $50,000
so yay anonymous people there will be an
IndieGoGo page up around December 16th
and while your donations are not tax
deductible all of the proceeds will go
directly to the project for awesome
charities last thing project for awesome
calm is not quite live yet but you
should go there right now and sign up
for the mailing list even if you signed
up for last year's mailing list that's
no good because we trash the mailing
list every year because we hate spam so
go sign up you will only receive email
about this year's project for awesome
nothing else ever I promise ok I gotta
take that did I have to go call the Yeti
and tell her the good news dftba I will
see you on Friday it looked like I was
pointing my pants when I said I was
gonna call the gate I was pointing at my
phone
you